russia's prison service says jailed
opposition leader alexey navalny has
been transferred to a medical facility
the announcement comes after navalny's
doctors said he was on the brink of
death and needed urgent treatment
and after western power warned of
consequences if naval navalny died in
prison
the 44 year old has been on hunger
strike for three weeks
after being denied access to his own
medical team the kremlin says nabalny's
health should not be of interest
to western countries let's bring in
russia analyst constantine
constantly we understand that navalny
has been hospitalized now
what do we know about his medical
condition right now
well the thing we know is from an
official press release of the
russian prison service which says that
he's been given vitamins which
could indicate anything actually what
we've known from
his doctors who analyzed his tests that
were passed on as far as i understand by
his lawyers
he has significant callium problems
in his body that's what they said
and that is quite dangerous
for him but the fact that he was
transferred from prison
gives a tad of hope that
maybe doctors will be allowed
to finally visit him but also
it gives ground to thinking that
probably his condition is such that
he definitely needs to be transferred to
a better medical facility than just a
uh prison medical point which is uh
quite scarce
but the eu's top diplomats are
discussing a navalny situation today
but can they actually do anything
well i think that mr putin is playing
his favorite game
of who blinks fast with navalny's life
actually
and with the west in general not only
with the eu
but my suspicion is that
maybe what mr putin wants he wants him
out of russia
and maybe to exchange for
let us say high-profile russian prisoner
for example
victor but a pilot who's been
running guns an hour's mother
essentially who's serving a sentence
in the united states uh i suppose that
putin thinks that navalny inside russia
is really dangerous because he see he is
a symbol and he is a
focal point of discontent
but i do think that to get navalny out
of russia
one needs a massive appeal and
probably personal phone calls from
people
whom putin wouldn't be able to refuse i
don't know whether it's pope francis or
angela merkel but it definitely
i think is a game that putin is playing
now and
uh navalny's health is on the line
he's playing this this international
power game on several fronts there
that's russia's true build-up on
ukraine's border and the
growing tensions between russia and the
czech republic
will that put even more strainer for
example on eu-russia relations
yes and i think that uh on wednesday
on the 21st of april when putin
addresses the federal assembly
both houses of parliament with his
annual address we are bound to
hear something spectacular it may be
introduction of russian troops in
belarus
uh which will be another part of the
ukraine build-up because just if you
look at the map
it will uh open the possibility for
russian troops to
mess on northern border of ukraine
another thing uh
could be also uh something concerning
relations with the eu
on nato in the wake of this czech
uh spy scandal which you mentioned uh i
do think we
at a point of crisis which personally i
haven't seen
since 2014 and the opening or beginning
of conflict between
russia and ukraine if you take it better
if you take it
so sorry further back probably 1983 with
the tensions between andropov and reagan
and
uh and pershing missiles in europe so i
think that
it is an inflection point for putin
we'll see what he has in store
on the 21st of april
thank you very much for that analysis